I'm very glad to have Jason with us
today and thank you men for coming and I
guess I'm gonna start with a very simple
question which is well how did it all
start it started with a realization that
the video camera was a tool for
immortality and that realization came
about and around the same time in which
I realized that we were mortal so it was
like the first thing that I jumped at as
an antidote to the terrifying
realization of what it means to be a
finite being I think that's the end of
childhood is the moment you learn about
death for you did it come at what age
well let's see my first video camera if
i watch those old clips of that the
camera where I was actively recording
with was I guess 19 1993 and I was born
in 82 so I guess like 11 11 12 years old
where that existential realization
became real and then the magic of the
camera to control time and to capture
time and to immortalize that which is
fleeting and you could argue that the
very beginnings of what eventually
became shots of awe was simply again the
creative power of being able to capture
time to capture ephemerality and I found
that tremendously fulfilling right away
even though all the videos that I used
to do when I was little I was behind the
camera I wanted to be the director I
wanted to be like a film maker by
definition
and it wasn't until maybe high school
when I was like 15 16 that I started
hosting these salons with my closest
friends in my house like in the terrace
of my house in Caracas Venezuela when I
was like this one yeah
very much so and it was full of my mom's
art because my mom is an artist and a
sculptor and a teacher and a poet and so
I was surrounded by her art and we used
to host these salons and you know we'd
get together Friday night and smoke some
weed and get in the zone and in the haze
of that inevitable hilarity in in in in
the haze of those giggles and and those
evocative contemplations that emerged in
that in those gatherings with my friends
the the kind of urge to record the
conversations that were transpiring
emerged as well and and what would
happen is that we would we would evoke
such a reverie like me with my friends
like the conversations took us out of
time and I would characterize myself as
slightly neurotic and so neurotic people
we we spend a lot of time in our heads
it's hard for us to be present because
we're always kind of pre assessing
what's gonna happen and or stuck in the
past and in those conversations with my
friends I found a lot of freedom and a
lot of presence that was rare and some
part of me even though I was when you're
fully in the present you're not supposed
to record it because you're supposed to
be in the present put down the goddamn
camera right but for me somehow some
partner was like you know what to record
this record what's happening and it was
upon the playback of that that I had a
another big aha moment which was seeing
myself wasn't that when I was not in
myself so people the word ecstasy means
to be beside yourself and and people
often say you know the only thing
getting in your way is you
and you want to aim to trance
and yourself or a flow state offers
freedom from the inner chatter all those
things and it was something about the
playback of the footage of those common
evocative conversations with my friends
and witnessing myself later in a state
of no-mind that I was like oh wow like I
can hold a conversation
I have a natural expressive body
language like I didn't recognize that
person because I was such an introvert
and so that immediately was like oh like
this is fun like I think you know so
even before you you went to study film
you already had found out that you could
use technology to enhance your better
moments yeah yeah there's a and this
I've come to realize this later
so there's a the guy his last name is
Cooley and he developed this theory of
how personhood emerges it's called the
Looking Glass self and basically it has
to do with the fact that our sense of
self emerges in the feedback loops with
other people and through the the
mirroring that takes place when we
interact with others and there's a
famous line that it's a play playing
Words but it says you know I am not who
I think I am and I am not who you think
I am but I am Who I think you think I am
so we make a mental model of another
person right I infer your mental states
and then I also make a model of what I
imagine your model of me is and then I
try to live up to that that's how we
connect with people am I am I being who
I think you think I am or am i improving
the model that I think you think you
have of me you know and and I did that
to myself with the videos because the
witness in the video was that other
person it was that objective perspective
and then evoking a flow state or evoking
those interesting contemplations and
those conversations with friends in that
reverie in that ecstasy in that
philosophizing right in that thinking
out loud I found freedom for himself and
in the recording and playback later the
neurotic me found comfort
and seeing that the me that was loose
and free and creative didn't need the
neurotic me to do his thing man I think
this is very interesting here's one of
the main things with your roses is you
you cannot hold in your consciousness
your interior version in your exterior
version and you did that being very
intense inside and then watching
yourself being intense yeah like it was
like a interesting hack for me because
anybody who is introverted is probably
aware or familiar with what it's like to
be extremely self-conscious you're just
like you're just so stuck in your head
you know you're the guy that doesn't
dance at parties because he's so
concerned about how ridiculous he's
gonna look um and so you know I still
don't really dance at parties but I
found my dance and I found a dance that
upon later reflection I was able to
trust myself to perform to do and so
just like a surfer who discovers his
love of losing himself in the surf or a
piano player who you know after 10,000
hours of practice can just get out of
his own way that was the beginning of
like okay I am going to a create
contexts in which I can transcend the
perception of the passing of time so
immortality now the Eternity in the
moment you know the world in a grain of
sand heaven in a wild flower infinity in
the palm of your hand eternity in an
hour
I figured out the precursors the
preconditions to evoke those altered
states of consciousness those poetic
liminal mythopoetic trances that poets
going to that artists going to the
filmmakers going to I figured out how to
create the conditions for that and then
like a flame those states of
consciousness would emerge and then I
figured out a way of capturing that so i
evoke the timeless I like to think but
then I have a tool that can capture the
timeless and bring it back into time so
then those videos themselves or Windows
or poor
into the timeless so then I became
obsessed with that with capturing
liminal states with capturing
mythopoetic states with capturing
ineffable states because isn't that what
we're always told about the greatest
states of consciousness that human
beings are privy to those spiritual
transcendental realms of the psyche you
know they say oh you can't put it into
words it's ineffable you can't language
those experiences they belong to God and
I'm like okay [ __ ] it so we're like
Prometheus we're stealing fire from the
gods like we I I made it a personal
challenge it became an obsession for me
to find ways of languaging ineffable
states the interior states that language
normally doesn't do justice to I wanted
to do justice to and I'm not the only
person who does this any artist musician
painter or poet is using the tools at
his disposal to communicate that which
is beyond all tools and that's a fun
game right so you just found a way of
keeping the best energy moments of your
adolescence in a sense after that when
you went to school you just read about
the theories that explain those moments
but you kept them yes so you know I'm
probably butchering the quote but
there's that whole idea of like having
like choosing to hold on to childish
things
that most of us as we become adults we
surrender and we let go of our childish
aspirations those youthful endeavors
those states of mind those endless
summers that characterize our childhood
before you know the sobering realities
of adulthood and finitude cloud our
dreams and I just remember that the the
purity and the ecstasy of those states
of being in which I found a reconnection
with that endless summer vibe and in
which I found freedom from the now
imposing constraint of
I'm passing house like no no these these
portals these states of consciousness
are my salvation you know I don't want
to grow up if growing up means growing
old and dying or even dying before you
die tensity of both of those moments oh
yeah absolutely is it yeah I mean my
buddy Jamie Weil who co-wrote stealing
fire he calls these these moments the
the remembering of the forgetting so
it's like yeah a menaces is the word so
you forget that you forgot and therefore
you remember yeah you remember and so
you're you're you're a child again
you're eternal again you're divine
again not because it says so in a book
not because someone else tells you you
are but because you know it implicitly I
think the word is maybe like cattle
Epps's which means a truth from which
nothing can dislodge us you know that's
when the knowing comes from within
catalysis is a word that I came across
that described this and I guess it's the
Greek word for a truth from which
nothing can dislodge us and I would
argue that so much of the human
experience so much of human truth the
truth of mythology the truth of poetry
is this truth that is cataleptic a truth
from which nothing can dislodge us that
comes from within it's the truth of
direct experience is the truth of felt
experience it's the realm of poetic
facts so in a sense you've become kind
of Epiphany reporter yeah that's why the
shot so far also called shots of
philosophical Express oh that's right
do you want to wake people up doing them
yeah there is a documentary that I was
obsessed with many years ago about the
work of Ernest Becker for those that
don't know Ernest Becker wrote the
denial of death was a Pulitzer
prize-winning book from the 70s about
the human condition and essentially
about how our unique kind of
consciousness the level of
self-awareness
self-awareness that we have allows us to
travel in time and project ourselves
into the future something most animals
cannot do all both I mean animals cannot
do and somehow we can but with the gift
of projecting ourselves into the future
and being able to plan and design and
imagine and create also comes the
capacity to project ourselves into the
future and see that we grow old and die
and so the book basically says that
that's the crux of the human condition
it's like well once you've made
once you've fulfilled your basic needs
for food and for shelter and for family
that's when you get like really
existentially depressed because now you
have to fight for meaning in the face of
death which is very hard and so that's
what the denial of death is about and
this documentary flight from death
looked at his work and I remember the
production company was called
transcendental media and their log line
was to agitate the sleep of mankind and
this was like 2008 that I was like
obsessed with this film so that's over
ten years ago and since then that line
struck with me I'll say oh yeah that's
what I want to do or as I don't want my
videos to do hopefully at their best
when they work to agitate the sleep of
mankind you know one thing I've been
doing watching one of your videos each
morning before starting work beautiful
makes a difference you're almost kind of
human Starbucks nice really words I used
to call my videos shots of philosophical
espresso and then we went with shots of
awe because it was just snappier but in
a way like philosophical espresso was
what it was right because it's a
condensed and compressed version of a
philosophical download a profound
epiphany hopefully right cuz I never
recorded myself unless I was actually
having an experience a profound
experience my videos were a response to
something happening inside of me and
Terence Mckenna the psychedelic
philosopher you know he
he writes and he spoke a lot about
psychedelic experiences experiences in
which huge michelle finn a realm beyond
the bounded self and I think Timothy
Leary referred to these moments as
exhilarating neuro storms of intense
intellectual pleasure tim duty says in
these moments you recontextualize the
self and you see your sense of self
instead as a marvelous conduit in a
timeless hole from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again in other words moments in
which you become one with the cosmos you
know and McKenna said that in these
moments these moments they demand a
response in much the same way that
getting slapped in the face demands a
response you can be like a calm person
or not a very expressive person but if
somebody comes up and smacks you over
the face you're gonna respond and
certain these experiences demand a
response so for me making the videos
capturing these moments capturing these
truth bombs these philosophical espresso
I decided very quickly I was like oh I
can't plan what I'm gonna say nor can I
outline nor can I write a script or
anything like that because that would
rob the videos of their authenticity
because what I actually want to capture
is more than what I'm saying when I want
to capture as a state of consciousness
and in order to capture a state of
consciousness I have to evoke a state of
consciousness so the closest thing to
outlining what I was gonna make videos
about was in creating the initial
conditions to evoke an altered state of
consciousness a state of no-mind a state
of flow and then trust what would emerge
and then record the response which I
couldn't help write because the
experience demands a response and then
watch yourself recorded and and think
about the next time and preparing for
the next time because what fascinates me
more is the experiment the whole
experiment you're doing with yourself
because you're you're just ingesting a
very condensed compressed version of
yourself that you're most yeah you
most intense moments so you're becoming
a very condensed version of yourself
you're curating yourself yeah all the
time
well it's very interesting because yeah
right in physics a singularity is what
happens when you go through a black hole
and one of the aspects of black holes
that have captured our imagination is
just the idea that the laws of physics
as we know them get real weird inside of
black holes and I would argue that any
epiphany that we have that occurs
outside of time is such a compressed
experience that it's like a singularity
and the laws of physics the laws of
awareness the laws of perception get
real weird in those altered states so to
evoke those altered states to then
capture my response to those altered
states while in those altered states and
then watch the playback of the videos in
those altered states creates a very
interesting feedback loop of self
mirroring and Douglas Hofstadter
in his book Goodell Esther Bock
speculates about how consciousness
emerged and because you know the
consciousness is such a mystery but his
analogy for what consciousness is and
how it emerged applied to what I'm doing
you know the feedback question that it
creates is what am i doing to my
consciousness because he says basically
that our brains are hard drives they're
like media that store patterns right
that store data and that data mirrors
the world so we mapped the world and
then we mirror the world and then we
store in our brain a map a mirror of
that world so we have these models these
brains our media that store models of
the world right but the more accurate
that picture in the brain of the world
is right the more act the more dense
with data it is eventually that model of
the world that you're making in your
brain includes you as a member of that
world right so you're making a model of
the world but that world includes you in
it so you see that's where the thing the
camera flips on itself that looks at
itself and he's in his words were that
in the inevitable vortex of self
mirroring
is where a real causal I or ascends to
himself emerges and that's something
that we're all doing but to a certain
degree you could argue that the amount
of granularity that exists there the
amount of self mirroring will determine
the amount of consciousness that a
species or entity has so I imagine that
you know dogs are somewhat self-aware
but there's less self mirroring
happening humans are at this level and
then humans that do a lot of self
inquiry you could argue that they're
creating more self mirroring and making
that granularity deeper and perhaps
piercing modes of self-reflection that
are that are more profound I don't want
to you know assume that I've you know
make the claim that I'm doing that but
it's an interesting speculation yeah
because you you see what you do is very
original normally the path the
traditional paths of liberation to
enlightenment and means to undo you
yourself your personality or everything
that really refers to what you are
different from the other persons but
what you do is just the opposite
you intensify yourself in your
difference in your personality to such a
degree that perhaps you arrived as in a
certain level similar to those levels
but from the other Wow perspective
mm-hmm well see based on what you said
yeah and one way of spinning the whole
enterprise from a psychoanalytic
perspective is holy [ __ ] this is a very
very very very creative and
sophisticated but ultimately
narcissistic way of deny denying your
own mortality and trying to cement your
own specialness before the imaginary
gods
so it's an immortality project trying to
convince the forces that I can't see
that I am sufficiently unique to deserve
a Hall Pass that frees me from mortality
I can see
the way that that could be a portrayal
of what I'm doing that it's ultimately a
narcissistic project having said that
however that doesn't take into account
the hundreds of thousands and
potentially millions of people who have
become enriched by my content so you
could argue that any musician or any
painter who creates work and then looks
at his own work and then sells and
shares and is validated by his own work
is doing something very similar to what
I'm doing but if their work ultimately
enriches others then I think it's okay
and if in the end everyone dies anyway
the only response to the human condition
well there's two choices either accept
death with equanimity and grace which
Buddhists
tell Buddhism tells us or find an
immortality project that injects your
life with enough meaning so that you can
live with enough intensity that as
Bukowski said death will tremble to take
you and just you know live like that for
as long as you can you see if that all
were just a strategy not to change then
I would suspect something like
narcissism but you change a lot this is
what fascinates me as you always say
please you can explain this much better
than I do
what you design design you yeah you
change with your whole process you're
not the same right person you were when
you started you just intensified
yourself but you changed during the
process because because in a way the the
intensity the intensification of the
self structure is itself a modification
of the self structure and a refinement
of the self structure and a carving at
the self structure to sharpen it and
become is inevitably something different
sharper broader more articulate more
evocative more sensitive maybe so in a
way you could call the enterprise of
making art to the art of cultivating
yourself all right and if you share the
process then you're also cultivating
others by extent
by making it public that is a very
interesting thing although I would
definitely acknowledge that there are
aspects of my personality that cling to
my basic essence you can go back to
conversations I had in high school where
I said that aspects of my essence I was
unwilling to give up I was unwilling to
cede to time in a way there was like
just a fierce loyalty to my basic values
and my basic loves the things that
defined what I was about were things
that I wanted to live into and I wanted
consistency so there is definitely an
aspect that I was like this [ __ ]
doesn't get to change yeah but at the
same time the end result of almost all
your musings and videos is the moment of
very intense all and all isn't it the
moment when you dissolve into the
immensity of the external world and
you're not yourself any longer in you're
just part of the whole universe how do
you see it yeah I mean definitely is it
not that a way to forget everything well
things are limited it's a way of
forgetting your limitations or realizing
that you don't have limitations right
one or the other but yeah I think it was
just the capacity to experience that
realm of the timeless because all too
often the tic-tock tic-tock tic-tock of
all verrano's is it is is it just it's a
it's an existential bummer right like my
parents getting older like that sucks
you know what I mean or or looking at
pictures of 10 20 years ago that is a
weird trip like where to go to hear my
90 year old grandma say like Oh Jason
you just don't know I feel like it was
yesterday where did the time go you know
and she's talking about 70 or 80 years
like you know most of us here
our grandparents say that and we just
kind of smile reassuringly Pat them on
the back and change the subject quickly
but for me those conversations always
just leave a little faint disquiet
because I imagine a rain for her mental
state in that moment to say something in
a [ __ ] in a moment of contemplation and
to be like oh where did the time go what
it must be like to be 90 and ask
yourself where the time went
I can't imagine the the strangeness and
and I have compassion for that but yeah
yeah yeah what strikes me today in our
conversation is how time is the
protagonist of everything and and it's
interesting because I think you are a
kind of sculptor of time and for me your
revolutionary because yeah I guess you
found a way to present philosophy and
philosophical ideas in a very
contemporary way and this brings me to a
very specific question you you're
obviously a very well-read person but I
guess you're revolutionary because you
explain these things in a video format
so people who don't have time to read
and ponder on these questions and so can
absorb them through you through your
energy into your person so what do you
think is going to happen perhaps in
Jason's of the future I'm just going to
quote you instead of the books you put
yeah Wow
thank you for that I love that you used
the phrase sculpting in time I think it
was tear cough ski Tarkovsky the
filmmaker who describes cinema as a kind
of sculpting in time and I love movies
more than any other art form and I love
all art but like when you're in a movie
theater you know and it's and it's the
right film and you're in the right state
of consciousness you're just the right
amount of receptive and open and your
inner chatter is quiet enough
that you can assume the viewpoint of the
character quickly you can make what they
call the Dietetic shift where you're no
longer seeing things through your point
of view but you've assumed the viewpoint
of the character you're no longer
looking at the screen you're now looking
into the screen and out through the
character's eyes into the character's
world that experience of radical
decentering of radical empathy of
radical becoming someone else and that
someone else being the archetype for
everyone else because the character in
the film is not just you is he's
everybody else in the audience and she's
everybody else in the audience and that
in two hours of Cronos which is their
average running time of a film you can
experience a lifetime of transformation
and Kairos which is subjective time make
cinema what I think is a metaphysical
portal two dimensions of the human
experience that hint at divinations
beyond measure and as Ursula Le Guin
said science describes accurately from
the outside so that would be yeah cinema
is 24 frames per second it's a two-hour
running time of the story it's edited
like this you know science describes
accurately from the outside but poetry
describes accurately from the inside
right science explicate s-- poetry
implicates both celebrate what they
describe so the interior experience of
watching a movie of losing yourself and
becoming immersed in a piece of media
that carries you away to a place beyond
death right through the looking glass
into the mythopoetic realm into the
liminal space into the threshold space
into the in-between space you know that
realm of light right because the
original celluloid works by shining
light through it you know makes cinema
the most magical thing in the world like
proof that we are greater than we know
and so for you to describe shots of Oz
sculpting in time I'm flattered
because I'd always wanted to be a
filmmaker
that reason I wanted to weave that wand
I wanted to be a sorcerer of cinema but
I think I lacked the discipline and the
wherewithal to work on a two-hour motion
picture and to manage 300 people in a
crew and to go through the arduous
process of what it takes to make an
actual feature film I bow down before
those that do that so I thought well I
have the technology to maybe make
something transcendent in three minutes
but less steps to get there you know but
the fact that you find it a form of
sculpting and time is very generous of
you to say thank you you you you you
make poetry for yourself for your own
enjoyment to begin with and I think one
of the main messages is you can do this
each and every one of us can do this to
make poetry and poetry as the Greeks
used to say it's it's for yang is simply
to make things up
and so it's like magic and you create
your own reality and your experience and
you curate that and you you live that
and because you believe in the maps of
your own creation is everyone for sure I
mean I just you know Ernest Becker and
denial of death it says that the entire
personality structure is essentially a
house of cards
the whole substructure of being identity
the whole thing is a ultimately an
illusion a virtual reality a story a
narrative right a story you tell
yourself about yourself that hopefully
serves you and Orient's you in the world
in a way that allows you to persist and
so Becker in denial of death argues that
we have to sustain this narrative either
through a religious affiliation or
cultural affiliation or romantic love
and be mirrored by that person who
approves of you invalidates you through
the movies that you that you associate
with and so on and so forth but he says
ultimately this is a fragile illusion
and I would argue that like a dream you
know dreams could be described as
illusions virtual realities could be
as illusions but this guy called rich
Doyle he wrote in his book Darwin's farm
as he said dreams do not lack reality
for they are real patterns of
information so it's like when people say
yeah well the self is a house of cards
and the self is an illusion and you're
only one bad day from going crazy it may
be that the self is sustained by
mechanistic realities right it's
sustained by a mortal body and it's
sustained by a body that needs to eat
and sleep and so on and so forth you
have to take care of the machinery that
runs the celluloid that runs the movie
but the movies real man it may not be
made of flesh right the body's made of
flesh the movies not but the movies real
it's a real disclosure your platanus I
didn't know that you believe in a realm
outside of ourselves at you I guess so
because you live there ah because you
mentioned neuroscience all the time and
dopamine and the workings of the of the
brain but you admit that there's
something else in a way at least in your
knowledge I do but I just haven't seen a
way of inhabiting or dwelling in that
something else without running the
machinery of the physical mortal body
yeah so if I'm in the movie theater I've
been having a transcendental experience
but if the power goes out or if somebody
turns on their cellphone or if the movie
projector fails the dream will collapse
like they say in Inception and in much
the same way the self structure that
runs in the mind that we can author
and/or create and evolve and steward is
running on you know heart pumping breath
gasping decaying bodies this is the
conundrum is that we are gods and we are
worms or as Ernest Becker says God's
with anuses and so [ __ ] you know like
[ __ ] like I think yeah I just I just
that's the that's the problem so it's
like that's that's also meditation that
you developed
to use using technology and philosophy
and your own rumination so pierce the
veil in get out of the matrix isn't it
yes yes yes I have moments of eternity
inside of parentheses love that
parenthetical eternities so yeah I can I
can stage a moment that unfolds in a
Euclidean meatspace universe and in
preparation for that I have to take care
of a physical body I have to sleep you
got to wake up and exercise have some
food drink some coffee make sure the
blood sugar is all good and then I have
a window inside that parentheses where I
know the machinery will sustain reveries
in the Platonic realm
until I have to pee until I get thirsty
until I get tired oh I have to leave the
movie in the middle of the movie to go
pee [ __ ] don't you hate that when you're
watching the best movie ever and then
you're like oh my god biology beckons I
have to go pee bad sculpting of time bad
sculpting of time but um but yeah yeah I
just I think there was this wonderful
article called the death of aw in the
age of awesome and this guy Henry wise
Meyer said experience is the new faith
and we are refugees from the mundane and
I don't think there's there's nothing
new there but he was trying to express
it as something new and Kenard
contemporary world because maybe
traditional religion is not as appealing
to highly educated people and there's
this kind of general malaise and
discontent and jaded miss about the
state of things and so now what people
crave is visceral and intense
experiences we're in the experience
economy throw yourself off an airplane
fly to South Africa to go on safari go
drink three bottles of ayahuasca so that
you can have an experience all in
counter with the numinous so experience
is the new faith it's the new it's it's
the new thing that we bow down before
it's not before the gods but it's before
an experience a willingness to submit to
new experiences right because if you
cannot submit you cannot die metamour
metaphorically speaking of course and if
you cannot die you cannot be reborn and
we're all looking for ultimately every
day is Resurrection jami'a wheel calls
it the Bliss [ __ ] crucifixion you know
and yeah I forgot where I was going with
that too many places is always so many
places but you see I love it when you
when you say that religion is not the
best solution any longer not even
romantic love
even if I'm very fond of it but
creativity is the better solution yeah
and I think that we could we could
borrow from religion into our creative
pursuits you know I mean [ __ ] if
somebody like gave me access to a Gothic
cathedral and allowed me to invite a
highly curated group of people and
install like crazy hans zimmer music and
give everybody a bunch of marijuana vape
pens and then like we could really evoke
some religious reverie you could call it
spirituality without religion there
doesn't need to be dogma just a couple
of rules to create the magic circle you
know in game theory they talked about
this an experience design is this new
science that is now becoming really
popular which is the art of experience
design of designing and crafting
interior experiences so using external
triggers to evoke interior States right
Eric Davis who wrote tech gnosis says
that our understanding of the neuro
chemistry of lived experience and the
effect of architecture music and all
these things to mediate consciousness
allows us to directly engage the
technical material of subjectivity
itself so now it basically gives us
authorship and stewardship of internal
life something we couldn't do before you
know you could argue okay go to a
concert it's gonna be fun it's not
necessary
gonna be fun it's only gonna be fun if
you're open and you respond to the
environment if you don't respond to the
environment it's not gonna work but the
better we get it hacking ourselves at
DJing our neurological response to
stimuli then we start be getting better
at being able to DJ our own experience
our own interior tea so we get we move
into a world of like designer realities
so it's not just like one religion for
all but it's like a thousand different
videogame religions pick your preference
you know pick your truth so curation of
experiences yeah is the key to
creativity in a sense well creativity
but also that that is that is that will
be the outlet that we turn to for
salvation from our rumination and
despair it's like ecstasy's for
everybody like democratizing the portals
for ecstatic experiences and and
bringing a thousand different options
instead of just one go to Burning Man if
you really want to see what the future
of experienced design looks like I mean
people think oh Burning Man is a music
festival it's not a music festival it's
a theater of the absurd constructed from
scratch for one week that is
self-selecting because it's so hard to
get there and Eric Davis described it as
millions of pocket universes collapsing
on a parched void so it's like it's it's
worlds inside of worlds with worlds
inside of worlds and and it's just an
unbelievable place and I think it's also
a glimpse of like like where we're
heading in terms of our New Jerusalem
one of the paradoxical things that
happens at Burning Man is you have
70,000 people experiencing a
choose-your-own-adventure because every
toy sends everybody tumbling down a
different rabbit hole and it's like just
unbelievable what transpires and the
permutations and combinations of
experiences that each consciousness is
having is like beyond measure this guy
called David Lentz and had this great
description of consciousness his
consciousness is a collaboration between
subject and object and so it's kind of
an equation to describe the interior
state or the interior experience of a
person
it's person x place x time which reveals
that bought his desk Garden of forking
paths of possible conscious experiences
so you have millions of those happening
at Burning Man and yet all of them lead
to the same place so it's a thousand
roads to God because at the end
everybody watches the man burned
together and it actually becomes a
communal ecstatic experience my friend
Jamie Weil who wrote stealing fire has
this wonderful trifecta and he says its
first is ecstatic
so the initial experience of freedom
from Sall freedom from inner chatter
freedom from neuroses freedom from
second-guessing freedom from fear
freedom from self that's ex taxes that's
followed then by catharsis catharsis is
where the cognitive dissonance heals
where the tears are shed where
revelation is felt I mean that's where
the healing happens so you have ex
tasses followed by catharsis and then
the last one is como Nita's on the other
side of catharsis on the other side of
those tears you break the isolation and
now you have a common experience with
everyone else we can all amend to our
brokenness together and walk each other
home as Jaime will would say look I get
goose just saying so the greatest work
of art is the work of art of your own
life but the very greatest work of art
is our lives together yeah both of them
yeah I mean the dance goes together man
it's it's like the end of the
documentary flight from death the
narration was a quote by Jean jean-paul
Sartre says everything has been figured
out except how to live and then the next
line he says so perhaps the better
question is not what are we to do with
death but what are we to do with life
life exists in individual moments and it
is up to us to make sure those moments
are vital interconnected and grand
to make a masterpiece out of life one
that we would willingly live again and
again for all of eternity this is what
we can strive for hmm so in a sense
you're an existentialist really because
it's about choices and choices and
choices you know freedom to choose well
I used to call shots of our existential
jazz the jazz part of course is because
jazz is an art form characterized by
freestyle free association improvisation
and existential because all the themes
are engaging with what it means to be a
sentient being you know every shots of
all episode ultimately brings brings the
the subject at hand back to the question
of what does it mean to be a thinking
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and some might say
Sheldon Solomon said ultimately no more
significant than a lizard or a potato no
but Alan Harrington would say well
having invented the gods we can turn
into them so choose your cues your cues
your platitude you know choose your
truth yeah because a potato doesn't
invent its own technology that's right
this that's right can move the camera
and rent it but not a potato doesn't
write poetry man that that reason alone
is what makes me think that we're
special these reason enough to wake up
in the air yes yes yes you're very
yeah you're very positive in your
message but what do you think about the
future are you positive regarding
technology and its possibility of
solving the problems itself at create
yes yes and in the first side note is of
course I'm aware that technologies
create unintended consequences for sure
but the solution to those unintended
consequences is simply the deployment of
better technology we can't go backwards
we can only move forward but the truth
of the matter is that when we move past
the rhetoric science is the only news
everything else is the same he says and
she says and science and technology is
the only way we've ever actually solved
problems it's like that line from Dead
Poets Society when Robin Williams is
talking about poetry and then he says
you know science technology engineering
these are noble pursuits necessary to
sustain life but poetry poetry is what
we stay alive for so we need both and I
want both and I celebrate both and most
of the corporate talks I do are about
exponentially emerging technologies
which are ultimately extensions and
embodiments and literalization of human
creativity and will in the world tools
and instruments and technologies that
literally not just metaphorically
augment extend and overcome our
limitations and allow us to work
together right we may be stuck flawed
stumbling primates but when we work
together we are primates that can fly we
build aircrafts we build cathedrals we
build smartphones we speak to other
minds across the planet collapsing
geography time space and distance are
not limitations for us like we are the
music makers are the dreamers of dreams
it's just we often don't have the
consciousness to deploy these tools in
the right way or many of us don't deploy
these tools in the right way some people
are gonna spend their whole time eating
junk food with technology you know
consuming mindlessly and entering
zombified trance States and whatever to
each his own but the tools are there for
us to make music my friends and we
should celebrate that good can you
imagine schools in the future
concentrating focusing and learning
teaching exactly this so well we're
trying some friends of mine have a
startup called the aw Academy which is
actually using a lot of shots of our
videos in their curriculum and the whole
aim of it is to bring the sensibilities
of cosmological existentialism oh and
Wonder into the classroom and so
hopefully we'll have some success with
that so yeah you've mentioned technology
and at the same time I think that your
favorite technology is just language I
mean you have a way with words
but the funny thing you also from
Venezuela you speak Spanish and imagine
was your mother tongue or not
yo Chrissy con la lengua
nice in Caracas so even a Solano
mentiras OE SS u da daaaa porque la
familia de mama americana mia whele say
mudo de nueva york Caracas Cano Seca so
homey abuelo entonces my Madre nación
Venezuela pero completamente bilingue
con mama Americana mi papá Vanessa
Vanessa la no y entonces yo yo McCrea
con la lengua at the same time
elementary school for him escuela
Montessori in Spanish but then seventh
grade I already switched to the American
school better at home yeah I mean I was
fully bilingual from day one beginning
from day one season and you you feel
different than you switch languages and
you you you see the world differently
when you switch languages well yeah I
mean there's a lot of interesting
articles and literature about that then
you get them by lingual ISM actually
makes makes you softer and stronger at
the same time by having two lenses
through which you see the world you get
the benefit of knowing that there are
lenses to begin with yeah because people
who speak one language they have one
worldview and one perspective for the
most part that which they perceive
reality and so when you only have one
perspective where if you worn glasses
your whole life and never taking them
off you forget that you have glasses or
you never learned that you even have
glasses right but when you grew up in
Venezuela Spanish and English went to an
international school with kids from all
over the world well it was like many
Solano americano Jewish Catholic Muslim
non-muslim Nigerian Indonesian and so
and in an environment in which you were
taught to embrace and respect
differences right emphasizing kindness
always it just I don't know it well I
think just by eventually it just makes
you aware that there are lenses of
perception so it makes you more
you have more cognitive flexibility when
assessing a situation because you can
quickly and automatically see it from
multiple perspectives you have the
sensibility of multiple audiences at
once and that's capacity to serve to
serve for situations better it gives you
again a cognitive flexibility linguistic
flexibility bit that is very
advantageous so in that sense it makes
you softer and stronger softer because
you're more compassionate and empathetic
to others stronger because you have more
tools in your toolkit with which to
solve and manage problems and your life
and engage with others this emotional
intensity you you you have to just to
convey does it come from the South
American toolkit definitely gusta Megan
tiene un poquito pero in Venezuela in
Brazil okay okay no sanke so Vanessa van
upon us in Tehran when they find out I'm
Venezuelan I met this I just met this
Venezuelan girl I was in Kauai in
Hawaiian there was a Venezuelan girl
that lived there was a fan of mine she
was like I used to watch your videos on
Facebook I knew you were Venezuelan even
before I knew you were Venezuela because
of the arms but for the average person
my largest audiences are in like New
York in LA online you know they're not
been as well so they just see all right
so passionately moves his arms like
that's so normal where we come from but
uh but it's very funny yeah for sure
they're just like what's your drinking
man exactly
I'll have what he's having yeah what is
he smoking you know yeah yeah so funny
well thanks a lot Jason for the
conversation it's been lovely
you